senators house au is the respondent
Donald John Trump guilty or not guilty a
question which Congress has wrestled
with for two months the impeachment
drama had reached its final act but the
ending had long been predicted mr. Casey
guilty mr. Cassidy mr. Cassidy not
guilty
two-thirds of senators needed to vote to
convict the president of abuse of power
and obstruction of Congress but they
failed to get even a simple majority it
is therefore ordered and adjudged that
the said Donald John Trump be and he is
hereby acquitted of the charges in said
articles but there was one notable
dissenter from the president's party the
man who was his predecessor as the
Republican nominee the president's
purpose was personal and political
accordingly the president is guilty of
an appalling abuse of public trust
corrupting an election to keep oneself
in office is perhaps the most abusive
and destructive violation of one's oath
of office that I can imagine Mitt Romney
was at times emotional as he spoke and
says he expects abuse from the president
for his vote mr. Trump denied he
pressured Ukraine's president to
investigate his Democratic rival Joe
Biden for corruption and almost all his
supporters agreed it certainly isn't
impeachable it's not even wrong quite to
the contrary this is exactly the sort of
thing the American people elected
President Trump to do Democrats tried
and failed to call witnesses like former
national security adviser John Bolton
instead the impeachment trial became a
daily soap opera which lacked new
characters and with the same script
lines endlessly recycled the Senate
should convict President Trump
remove him from the presidency and
disqualify him from holding future
office
the votes to acquit came less than 24
hours after the president delivered a
triumphant State of the Union address
saying the economy has never been
stronger and bringing his supporters to
their feet our spirit is still young the
Sun is still rising
God's grace is still shining and my
fellow Americans the best is yet to come
Nancy Pelosi Speaker of the House and
architect of impeachment caused huge
controversy with her response to the
speech it epitomized America's yawning
political divide but may alienate
independence for Democrats removal
through impeachment was always going to
be a long shot but the tactic may have
backfired he's still in the white house
it's now up to the voters as to whether
mr. Trump should be evicted in woods Sky
News Washington